good afternoon how are you doing awesome
after lunch coma hitting him so here's a
quick question who has ever seen me do a
talk or a presentation YouTube Noah
great so what happens is that every time
before I do a talk or a workshop or
whatever I get the people to do some
physical exercise now you may be
wondering why is he doing this
you just ate right you know we have to
burn those calories
number two is because I'm losing my
voice already it's because you know that
saying fresh body fresh mind so I want
you to be hundred percent concentrated
on what's going to happen here so in
light of this mm-hmm
try to not to lose my voice please stand
up and if you thought I'm joking I'm not
it's going to be it's going to be nice
so what I need you to do is going to be
very very very simple all you need to do
is lift up your arms like this
okay and clap
and you may sit down thank you very much
mm-hmm
so what just happened standing ovation
right this is how it's done
so what I do I keep on sending these
images to my boss and he's like how do
you do this on i.t conferences I'm like
yeah just get give me a pay rise and
I'll tell you okay and the reason why I
asked it because there are some people
like I did a meet up a second time in
the same group and then when I said oh
this someone see me talk before and they
were like five people already like I'm
like okay you know what's going anyway
progressive web apps is what we're going
to talk about today and my name is Tomas
I come from Hungary I lived in the UK
and Brazilian other places I work as a
developer evangelist at a company called
Cloud nari we're going to talk about
cloud me a little bit as well and quite
recently I was very very thrilled that I
got selected as a Google developer
expert in web technologies so that's
quite a good thing
also if you believe that you would like
to be a Google developer expert then
come talk to me and I can refer anyone
so if you interest in that please come
and talk to me so quick poll before we
get started who here knows what
progressive web apps are
huh just theory just a bit has heard
about PWA has put them together use them
seeing them off a few of you who here
has seen the serviceworker knows what it
is serviceworker api ok cache API
angular PW a plug-in network information
API ok so everyone's going to learn
quite a lot here I like that so let's
take a look at the agenda now I have to
admit something I had a problem problem
was that when I put together this
material I wanted to share so much
because there's so much about
progressive web apps I could talk you
know for two days just about this and
what I ended up doing is I created kind
of two sample apps one that I'm going to
show you I'm going to give you the code
we're going to go through it relatively
quickly and then we're going to put
together a relatively complex PW as well
which will also you know take a look at
the various parts and see how that works
now when I ask the question who knows
what the progressive web app is and who
has worked with service workers before
there were few of you who said you know
what it is but I just realized that the
majority of the people here are not that
familiar with that so we're going to
have a crash course on pwace and
serviceworker so i'm going to show you a
very very basic example so that you
understand how a progressive web app is
and what the service workers do and how
a service worker enables the PWA
functionality ok and then so for those
of you who already know this please bear
with me I just want to make sure that
everyone is on the same page so we're
going to take a look at progressive web
apps in general then we're going to talk
about service workers then we're going
to talk about this thing called work box
- yes anyone familiar with word box -
yes one ok so another 20 some people
will learn something and as I said demos
and we'll do some coding as well if time
permits but I'll try to speak fast so in
a nutshell what is a progressive web app
so there's lots of definitions but I
would like you to think about the
progressive web app as just the website
that acts as an application
and the key here is that it is a website
that acts as an application because
basically you can't say that every
website is a progressive web app but if
you enable some features for that
website that make that website have some
app like behavior then you can consider
that to be a progressive web app so what
are those features right if you think
about a native mobile application so
these are applications that you install
from your app store from Google Play
right so you look for it for an app
download it on your phone that is what
we call a native mobile app so those
native mobile apps have these features
amongst many things right offline
availability right so all the apps that
you have you may not have network but
you can still launch it and you could
still potentially interact with it right
if it's a news app you would probably
see other news and when you go online
then your news feed is going to refresh
right that's that's like a normal
behavior
you also get notifications so you get
some new notifications in the app and
what progress see web applications also
enable the for you to do is something
called adaptive performance so we're
going to take a look at a very nice
example on achieving this so essentially
I want you to remember this a
progressive web application that's the
first sentence here allows a web app or
a website to be accessible by anyone
regardless of what device they use and
where they are in the world meaning you
know what speed of network they use or
what their location is okay so the term
progressive in the progressive web app
also means that you give your users of
progressive enhancement for their
application meaning if someone is on a
2g network for example you definitely
don't want to for example stream an HD
video for them whereas if they are on a
Wi-Fi then you want to show them that
video okay so think about a single
article let's say it's about a sport
event where you want to show a nice
video of some action right if you detect
that your user is on a Wi-Fi show the
video if they are on a 2g or in a slower
Network then show them a picture instead
or maybe show them nothing right so this
is from
recive enhancement as well so I think
Google was the first company who who
come up with this sort of checklist and
you know the more of these you check the
the more likely that your application on
your website could be considered as a
progressive web app so the first one is
app like it acts and feels like a native
mobile app that's very simple
connectivity independent again very
simple stuff by the way the reason why
you see these weird bullet points is
because I just changed the theme for the
slide in the last minute because I
realized I had a dark theme and you now
wouldn't be able to read anything so
it's all going to be a bit weird
connectivity independent works offline
simple as discoverable means that you
can install this and find the PWA now
I'm going to link out to an interesting
article but we'll get to that as well
fresh meaning that you get you open the
app and it should automatically pull for
example the latest news so it's always
fresh if there's connection installable
that you can install it on to a mobile
device and we're going to talk about
this as well linkable that you can link
to it right so if you think about
applications on your mobile there's no
way that you can link to a native app
but because this is now a website
theoretically you could link to parts of
that as well
progressive we talked about that
reengage book means that once it's
installed your users can just get back
to it as easy as possible how do they do
that you will have a launcher icon in
the operating system on your mobile
device and they tap it and boom your app
opens responsive very straightforward
thing if you are using this app on a
tablet it should have the right
dimensions if use it on a mobile phone
you should have the right dimensions so
it's standard web development
responsiveness here safe progressive web
apps and especially the serviceworker
api dictates that you must use HTTPS at
all times okay so using HTTP will not
work with the serviceworker
okay so why progressive web apps there's
a lot of reasons now the what I
recommend you to do is take a look at
the resources that you can find on
Google's website after the latest IO and
they release some more use cases and
case studies they have a myriad of you
know use cases and what company changed
from what kind of application to a
progressive web app and they give you
all sorts of numbers that many users
that many sales which left to this and
left to that but essentially what you
need to remember is that for some
companies they had a website and then
they had a application in Google Play
for Android and for iOS right and the
users didn't like that and then they
said okay you know what I would just
create one simple website if my user is
on the on a desktop I will show that
website and then I'm going to make a PWA
out of that website so that if they're
on the mobile are we offered the option
for them to install that and then they
can just keep on coming back so it's
basically one code base that they have
to maintain it's really easy and there
are some links here that you can read on
how for example Pinterest and Twitter
achieved you know better performance
better sales better user retention
better user engagement by converting
parts of the applications or the entire
application to a progressive web app so
what are the core technologies that
enable the progressive web apps so let's
start with the me the second one service
workers so without the service worker
you wouldn't be able to create a
progressive web app and for those of you
who are new to this I'm going to show
you a very simple example and you will
understand why so without the service
worker and without using this thing
called a service worker API you are not
able to create a progressive web app so
that is the core to everything that is
progressive about then there's this it's
not really a technology it's more like
as you see a JSON file manifesto JSON
that contains a metadata about the
progressive web app we're going to take
a look at an example what that metadata
is but essentially it's things like
where is the icon that is going to
appear once you in
so all the app what should be the actual
icon launcher text for that particular
application and these are the things
that you specifying that manifesto JSON
file then we also have the cache in the
cache API right so if you think about
the progressive web app one of the key
pillars of that is that it allows you to
work offline right in order for it to
work offline it needs to store some of
your assets where does it store it it
will store it in the cache which you can
manipulate using the cache API
lighthouse is a tool again that I I
think it's created by Google but I'm not
sure it's definitely part of the chrome
dev tools as of version sixty something
it basically gives you a score value so
you can run some tests and it will tell
you oh you know what your progressive
web app is awesome you get a score of
100 or it's quite bad you got a score of
62 and they explain to you what you need
to change in your app in order to
improve that that's core and then quite
recently they started and when I say day
it's it's Google and the reason why I
mentioned Google so much it's not
because I'm a Google developer expert
it's also because they are one of the
big companies who are advocating
progressive web apps quite a lot so they
have a lot of resources and they put a
lot of investment into educating people
about this
so quite recently they have come up with
this PR PL abbreviation which they
pronounce as purple which is short for
push render free cash and lazy low and
what they say is that if you take all
these boxes then you're like PW a master
level 99 okay oh they're like the coder
for pwace but they also say that if you
just take either of these then you're
also making a step forward at least
having a better performing website okay
so push refers to the HTTP to push
thingy I don't know how that's called
the push whatever do you guys know what
that is okay so browser interaction 101
so what happens you have
your browser you have the Internet and
here's a web server okay so you type in
something CNN or Chrome for example and
we go out here this sends back the index
file so you get the index of HTML and
then your browser starts to parse this
file right it's going to find JavaScript
files and CSS files as it keeps on
parsing through your HTML file and it's
going to go to the server and say hey I
found a CSS file can you please send it
to me yes I can
okay now I have it so I will add the CSS
and understanding to my site okay this
is HTTP 1.1 this is how it works okay
HTTP the / - push works differently with
this you can sort of proactively tell
the server that when you request an
index file or index of HTML you also
want to request let's say an app dot CSS
file so what happens you go to a website
the server sends back index.html your
browser we start to parse it it will get
to the CSS state and it's going to want
to make a request in the server saying
hey could you send me that CSS file and
that point because you have asked that
file to be pushed the server has
assented that even before the browser
requested it right so the actual browser
is going to say you know what actually I
don't need it because it's already here
so it's just going to allow some there
are some keywords that I could throw at
you like multiplexing blah blah blah
doesn't matter just better performance
okay remember that render precache and
lazy load so pre caching is something
similar to push which allows you to sort
of pre cache your resources and there
are some techniques that allow you to
kind of correctively
get entire routes pre cached and I think
Google was it last year when they were
Nick
launched this machine learning based
pre-caching something so you basically
they learn the behavior of the users of
a website and they will ahead of time
believe that you will click a link and
they will precache assets that are
required for that link and when you
click on it it's going to load faster
lazy loading is another interesting
thing
imagine a a website that shows you
photos right a gallery of photos and
you're on your mobile device and you see
three images out of twenty okay so lazy
loading means that you should only load
those three images because there's no
need to load the other 17 because the
user is not going to see that so you
should lazy load it when the user starts
to scroll okay so they say if you adhere
to any of these or all of these then
you're going to have a much better
performing website and they also edit
these features to their progressive web
app collection of goodness whatever
okay so Service Worker so the Service
Worker I think the easiest way to think
of it is to think about it as a proxy
that sits between your browser and the
Internet or the server battery the site
is being returned from okay and I have
an animation it's probably a bit broken
but never mind
so the serviceworker itself lives inside
the browser so you need to have what
they call you know the modern web
browser so of course we had lots of
jokes before about IE 6 and 7 and 9 and
whatever older i versions don't have it
but most modern browsers including edge
of course have the serviceworker enabled
and you can use the serviceworker api so
normally what happens if you go out to a
particular domain your request goes to
the Internet to the server and then the
response gets sent back to the browser
and then the browser parses everything
but what happens when you have a
serviceworker enabled activated and
installed is that every single request
and response will go through that this
enables us
to do whatever we want with this request
and response cycle right it allows us to
sort of massage the request it allows us
to take some responses and put them into
the cache which is already leading me to
how we're going to utilize the service
worker and the cache API to make our
website work offline okay so the service
worker is the key that enables a
progressive web application purely
because it can intercept these requests
and you can do stuff with that request
so the other thing that we talked about
manifest file so it's a simple JSON file
that contains a lot more than this but
these are the key pieces of information
that you in my opinion at the bare
minimum should have as part of a
manifest file so add to homescreen
information what is the name of the icon
that you want on your mobile device
after you've installed the app so you
can specify that there where are the
icons for that app what orientation
should it should start in a horizontal
in a vertical mode background color and
startup pace what page should it launch
when you tap that icon so these are all
things that you can specify using this
manifest file and then the browser's can
of course pick this up and we'll see how
that works as well
cache API so probably very
straightforward the cache API allows us
to manage the browser's cache which
means that we can add SS to it we can
retrieve those assets the one thing that
I will point out here is that every
single browser from every single vendor
on every single machine so the cache
size and every single machine is going
to be different okay it's dependent on
your disk capacity depends on what
version of Chrome on what OS you are
using but the point of this is that you
know let's say you have a very nice
looking website which is very rich in
media so it's full of images and videos
and you say oh I'm just going to cache
everything right all the 500 megabytes
of images right you can't do that you
have to be wary of the fact that you
have a limited amount of space and there
are some strategies that you can use to
manage this space which
I think we'll take a look at as well now
caching strategies now there's more
caching strategies out there I'll tell
you why I chose this five there's a
particular reason why I'm showing you
these five caching strategies so
whenever you cache a resource or
whenever you create a progressive web
app you need to find into the
appropriate caching strategy and there's
these five ones let's start from bottom
to up here
so cash only what does that mean you
make a request for something that is
going to take a look inside your cache
let's say you requesting app dot CSS the
request is going to take a look in your
cache is it there if it is it returns it
if it's not boom I can't find it Network
only is the exact opposite of this it
will always go to the network to find
the resource if you never go to the
cache then we have cache first and
network first so cache first means that
you request AB dot CSS it will go to the
cache if it finds it in the cache it
returns it to your application if it
can't find it in the cache then it falls
back to the network so it will try to
make a network request and get that back
from the network
on the contrary network first works the
other way around right so you request a
block CSS if we go out to the network if
it can't find it or if there's no
network it will fall back to the cache
and then we have this very first one
stale while revalidate so this is an
interesting one this is almost like a
race between the cache and the network
so the way this works is that you
request AB dot CSS and it's going to be
a request to the cache and to the
network as well if it's in the cache
it's going to be returned from the cache
and then the version that it received
from the network will update whatever is
in the cache ok so that's why I stay a
while everybody died ok remember these
these are going to come back and then it
will all make sense why I talked about
these four five strategies so workbooks
there was one person who was familiar
with workbooks I think verbose jess is
super awesome like seriously if you've
ever written serviceworker codes you may
have come across situations where it
just becomes way too complex to manage
and there's lots of dark corners and
hidden things that you know hidden traps
that you can fall into so workbook GS is
basically a set of libraries that it's
almost like a wrapper or a layer above
the service worker and the caching api's
so basically comparing the code using
the cache API and the service worker
versus writing the same piece of code in
Berbick GS would be the matter of 20
lines versus one it's it's really good
so we're going to take a look at this it
has a lot of good options it basically
if you will ever create progressive web
apps then use verb boxes it's really
really easy to use it has a plug-in
based system you can write your custom
plugins there's a lot of options that it
can manage which would take a lot of
time to figure out using all these
native api's yeah it's just I'm really
happy that I found it and guess who is
the creator of per box yes
me Yeah right no Google but but thank
you
although I've wrote a plug-in but we'll
get to that
okay so progress Sababa so now you
hopefully know what a progressive web
app is or what to expect from it and
you're probably thinking oh that's great
but you know I use react I use angular
how can I use this thing so the good
news is that and this is just a very
short list if you google my favorite
framework PWA
I guarantee that you will find some sort
of plugin so for angular it's angular
/pwa so you need to DS ng add that and
then progressive web app support is
going to be added to your angular app
similarly this is for view Knox GS is a
static site generator for view that
actually uses workbooks GS as well so
once you know how that works is just
apply all your knowledge there for react
you need to add serviceworker or you
just add work box to your project ionic
since that's based on angular that works
as well polymer has PW a starter kit and
as I said probably other frameworks have
that as well so the good news is that
the major frameworks have very good
support for progressive web apps okay
now we're going to talk about this thing
it's a putting concept in there because
it uses one of the it's not that new a
fairly new browser API called the
network information API so the network
information API basically anyone I think
I also but no one said you know ok so
what it does it tells you the connection
of the user is browsing your website so
basically if your users on Wi-Fi on 4G
it's going to return a string called 4G
if they I use it on a 3G is going to
return 3G anything to G edge or lower is
going to return a string 2g or slow - 2g
what this means is that you can take
this information and act on it right so
you could do different renderings you
could do
and the example that we'll see is using
workbooks so you could for example
render lower quality images for users
who aren't a 3G device versus people who
use a Wi-Fi so the reason why it's a
concept is because of its I would love
for all the browsers to support this but
at the moment I think Chrome and maybe
Firefox supports it but I think the
others will hopefully soon support this
as well so we're going to take a look at
this as well because I have some code to
show you and we're going to go through
that right excited ok any questions so
far so I just put a few names like
Sydney there's an instant app it's
suddenly in my screen it works like an
epic I I don't know on the background of
something download or install probably
at some point you installed it yeah I
have yes it's not just going to crawl
its way into them while it sits you have
to that's going to be a prompt you say
install this that's going to be
something you know installing and then
the icon will appear
application okay okay well we can take a
look at that later but theoretically a
pitohui works after well it works
because it's a website so you can go to
any URL you can use the website or if
you want to use it as an app you would
have to install it but we'll be going to
take a look at that so where should we
start so if you don't mind I will sit
down for this quick poll is this tax
large enough it doesn't matter what it
says there but it can you guys see it in
the back and white background works as
well okay because I changed this last
minute as well so there's there are some
people are you know new to this whole
PWA thing so let me find a very simple
example
so I did a very simple I did a talk
yesterday about less technical PW stuff
for for a coding bootcamp so what I'm
going to do I'm going to take that like
a minified version of that talk and just
show you what a Peter way looks like in
one second
serviceworker code so at least for those
of you haven't seen it or you don't know
how to imagine this you will understand
it as well okay so let me reset a few
things here pretend you're not seeing
this now this is not happening
cool so here we have a very simple
website that has an h1 element okay
hopefully this is nothing too difficult
so we're going to launch this website
and what you will find is that when you
work with this serviceworker so a few
things I use Chrome almost exclusively
when I create pwace and I work with the
serviceworker other browsers as I said
support it but I find the chrome dev
tools and their overall support for how
you can debug and and take a look at
service workers to be the best ok so
that's why I'm going to stick to this
you can use any other browser if you
want so at the moment this is our
website ok so there's a reason why you
see that the serviceworker is read that
is because there's this advert CSS that
applies the style okay very easy to
understand so far so good
now the basic groups the basic premise
of a progressive web app is that when I
go of line is that let me remove the
hi I want to get rid of the okay this is
hopefully better so notice that and I
probably moved this but if you open your
dev tools you is that large enough for
you to see in the back okay you should
have that application tabs somewhere
okay I just moved it here because I
access it a lot in my dev tools and not
as it has manifest serviceworker storage
somewhere here it has cache so we're
going to use all of this because this is
the place that you want to be when you
create your PW and when you test it so
offline right so we want to make sure
that it works offline and probably this
is something that you've seen millions
of times right at the moment we have a
standard website we are offline nothing
works okay do you know how this thing is
called
so it's not Steve of Zilla or down-ass
or like down a socket but you know of
the game right
everyone knows the game jumpy jumpy no
okay back to pwace so it probably seen
this before right you don't have network
your site doesn't work so what can you
do to fix it well you can start working
with the serviceworker now the
serviceworker this is all what it takes
to enable the serviceworker itself okay
so we check whether the serviceworker is
enabled for the browser it's probably
good practice to do that because you
want to make sure that you know your
users don't get any errors and notice
navigated that serviceworker don't
register so don't register is one of the
methods that you can access in the
serviceworker
API which allows you to register the
serviceworker itself and the
serviceworker in our case is that
javascript file okay so the
serviceworker is just another JavaScript
file that you create so what happens is
that when you have this code the browser
is going to download register and then
activate that serviceworker okay so
theoretically if that's correct and this
is a promise based API we should see
that serviceworker is good to go message
in our console so konso just refresh
this site okay serviceworker
is good to go so that means that we now
have a serviceworker enabled activated
and ready to go so if I go offline that
should just work right no why because we
have just registered the serviceworker
but we haven't actually written any code
for the serviceworker we now need to
write the code for the serviceworker
itself okay hmm
so let's ignore that's there so let's
just collect all the files that make up
our application and put them into an
array okay so this is as I said the most
simple example that you will come across
probably index.html we have an Abbe doji
s and we have an app dot CSS these are
the three pieces of the three files that
make up our application so what we can
do is then this
so in line 8 we come up with a name for
a cache so that's going to be our custom
cache in the browser so I just gave it
the name my - cache self so when you
write serviceworker code itself always
refers to always refers to the
serviceworker execution contact so
that's like the this in the scope of the
serviceworker okay
so self dot and we add an event listener
on install so we say when the
serviceworker is being installed then
open a cache with the name my cache open
is going to either create our cache
we'll see what that means in just a
moment and then the real magic is cache
Edel files okay so it's going to create
that cache and it's going to add all
those files that we have specified from
lines so in that array for the files
does this make sense okay so let's save
this refresh or go back online
refresh this so we have serviceworker
it's good to go but now if under the
application tab I scroll down I have
this section called the cache storage
and if I expand that notice I have
something called my cache so that is the
cache that I've just created and if I
click on it I see that there are these
assets in that cache ok so now we have
any boardís cache so if I now go offline
will it work
no it won't why and just keep on doing
of it I like the down the store thing so
why it doesn't work we now have the
serviceworker we we now have these
assets in the cache but we never told
the browser what to do when it's offline
and how to get these items from the
cache right that is the last piece that
we need to add so how do I do that
so this is where the real magic happens
so the way the browser works is that
every time it requests a resource so it
requests a CSS file a JavaScript file
and index file it uses a fetch event so
it goes out and fetches a dot CSS
patches whatever to the debtor
okay so in the serviceworker we add an
event listener for the fetch event and
then the real magic happens in line and
19 so what happens so in that block line
18 - what 21
it basically says take a look at the
event request so the event request is
going to be localhost
something-something slash a dot CSS if
you find that AB dot CSS in the cache
that's the response did return it
otherwise so or go and run your standard
fetch event so try to go out to the
network so what this is going to do is
because we have we will have a match for
a dot CSS at the GS and index of HTML
all of those resources are going to be
returned from the cache itself so
actually that piece of code after the or
is never going to be executed right so
let's save this let's do go back online
refresh hit offline refresh oh ok ok how
is vary from one ok and stay and
everything works okay so I'm offline I
don't have network this thing still
works and if you take a look at here in
the console and not sure how much you
can see that but basically it says
request for AB dodea AB the GS and the
reason why I say this here is because I
added that log statement in the file so
now everything is being returned from
the cache so let me prove something to
you let's say I forget to add AB dot CSS
okay so I'm not adding that and here's
another thing so this is a good learning
moment as well every time when you work
with the service worker and pwace first
of all I already made a mistake you
should always test it on a private tab
because
having tested so many PWA sometimes I go
to local host port something and
something there's opens even though I'm
not running anything I'm like what so
you will have this very fun things going
on
this is the magic reset button here
clear storage okay so you will use this
this is going to be your best friend so
if you scroll here there's this clear
side data make sure that everything is
checked and as you can see it's going to
unregister
all the active service workers it's
going to clear the cache so basically
it's like your big red reset everything
button to normal okay and this is very
useful because sometimes you will run
multiple service workers in multiple
ports and it just gets all very
confusing you come here clear everything
start from scratch okay so that's what
I'm going to do now make sure everything
is deleted and now okay it doesn't work
so let's go back online so when we are
online we get the standard functionality
but when we go offline remember we now
did not add a dot CSS to the cache so
when we go online we no longer get the
stylesheet applied we still get the
content but because F dot CSS is not in
our cache there's no way that the
browser can get to that so it will
render whatever it can without the CSS
okay so this is your most basic PWA
works offline for those of you who are
new to this does this make sense clear
as mud okay
two techniques you use from the here
it's this is cash first cash for because
you go to the cash first and then you
fall back to the network
so whatever the name of that was any
questions so far
sorry what time I finish I might finish
that's four or five four i doesn't know
because I can but I think I don't have
it here for 30 mm-hmm perfect
so any questions no yes
so I can't hear well yeah there was a
reason for that but I forgot there's a
particular reason for that which I can't
remember but it could be yeah it could
be to do something with how the service
worker looks at the scope of your app
but I'm not I'm not sure but I need to
check that up and now I'll try to find
it for you okay so from this you now
understand how this all works but where
is it you know let me show you another
basic example and then we'll
progressively go to the sort of harder
examples PWA code I wasn't planning on
showing all this but this is another
good example so nodes server is so this
is running on low cost 80 so this is a
slightly more complex example let me
just clear everything because god knows
what I've done before so being reset but
oh you see I was actually offline I just
loaded something that's what I'm saying
it's crazy so I'm online it will load
probably the same thing but okay so this
example is kind of the same but it has
one extra thing added to it this is like
a news website which I'm not a designer
as you can tell by the-- wonderful is
that this took me like a day just to
make it look like this the only
difference here is that this time the
data that you see here is coming from an
API ok so there's actually if I go to
locos API slash
news this is the raw data that gets
parsed and displayed to you ok so this
is assuming that we grabbing data from
somewhere and displaying it in the
application itself and
and you will see that if we go offline
this whole thing still works okay so I'm
not able to refresh in a sense that I'm
not able to go out to the API and get
the latest data but still I can just see
the data that was there when I lost
refresh the application when when I was
lost online so the way this is done is
it's all in this cache thingy here so
let's close this so now you will see
that I have two caches I have this news
cache which is again just the JavaScript
file the index file and also what I want
you to notice is that this looks a bit
weird like slash Ajax slash libs etc if
you take a look at the serviceworker
file itself for this particular
application you will notice that you can
not only cash resources that are local
to your device but you can also go out
to a third-party CSS file or JavaScript
file and put that into your own cache as
well ok so that's what I'm doing and if
you look carefully there's another cache
storage here called PWA news data cache
which just contains such API news but if
I click on that I probably need to the
this way ok what you see here is that
the entire response from the API is also
cached so this is what allows me to
basically fetch this even though when
I'm offline ok but it makes sense to put
this into a different cache right
because you want to make sure that your
assets are different from the API why
the API response inside the cache is
likely to be updated more frequently
than your static assets right it's not
likely that a CSS file or a JavaScript
file is going to change every time when
you go online whereas the actual
response from a news API is going to
get updated so this application does a
few more additional things first of all
it has a manifest.json file so you can
take a look at a very basic one here so
named PW a news short name name and then
an icon which is an array of objects
that specifies the icon in different
sizes for when you install this app and
we're going to take a look at that in
just a second where the browser should
look for the actual icon and on top of
that we also specify the start URL so
when it is installed and when you tap it
on your mobile where it should start so
it's the root display stand-alone so
this is what's going to render our PWA
in a separate window so it's not going
to open the browser is going to open a
separate window on the device and then
background and theme color you will see
that in just a second and there's one
more thing that this particular
application does it accepts push
notifications so push notifications are
a bit tricky because every push
notification that you have or that you
want to any boom must go through a
third-party service ok the reason for
this is because imagine that you allow
push notifications and then I as a
developer can just spam you with
whatever I want ok so it has to go
through a service and that service will
send out a notification to all the
devices that have any border allowed the
notifications to happen and how do I
know that I have notifications enabled
this is particularly in chrome you know
you click this icon and notifications is
allowed so when it's asked default what
happens is that you know we refresh this
site and probably you've seen this
before
right big magic reset button where a
website does something similar to this
okay
this means that that website is likely
to be a progressive web app and they
want you to accept notifications a
notification can happen on certain
conditions so I'm going to allow this
and then fingers crossed I'm going to
try to send a notification to this app
using in some new arm so what I'm going
to do and the way this is done is I will
send an HTTP POST I'll zoom in on this
sorry it's too dark maybe so I'm going
to send an HTTP POST with a hypothetical
new article to the API slash news and
point that I have and the way I've set
up this application is that if there's a
new article added the PWA should receive
a push notification ok telling the user
hey there's a new article that just got
added so finger crossed 50% chance that
this is going to fire okay so I'm going
to sand and there we go
okay so I receive the notification and
what I did I just put in the title and
the name of the author it's now gone to
the notification okay now theoretically
there's a lot more that you could do I'm
not refreshing the newsfeed but you
could also do that automatically and
there's a whole lot of things that you
could do now one more thing that I want
you to realize and we're not going to
get into the details of that but if I
open the serviceworker
this is it right it's it's complex okay
there's a lot happening here the reason
why I'm showing this to you is because
this is using the serviceworker api and
it's using the cache API so it's using
these native things next up we're going
to take a look at a word box example and
hopefully you will see that all of this
is just going to be literally about ten
lines of code or maybe less okay
any questions on this we're not going to
talk about this web push thing there's a
an NPM package that one second there's
an NPM package allows you to do that
pretty much out of the box it's called
web - push
so NPM iWeb - push you just get some API
keys but I'll get you this code so you
can see how it's done yeah
could I just show you D yeah so what
happens there is it's basically this bit
here so lines 36 to 50 something so what
oopsie
sorry so what happens is that we take a
look at the request URL and if it
contains slash API slash News then we
put stuff into the data cache otherwise
so this is the code that you've already
seen before in the very simple example
that's exactly the same and then here we
have casually put and we put a cloned
version of the the response that's how
you would do it for the API I also want
you to kind of not memorize it but just
remember sort of how complex lines 43:49
look like and then I'm going to show you
the world box equivalent of that which
is believe it or not one single line of
code
yeah
at the ATM alliance of opera apply yep
is there the p-doped realized in Bexley
and another version of
Oh like how do you okay so how does the
browser know where the manifest file is
kinda yes or if I could be the forgot
that right here right so it's your index
of HTML you have to point to the
manifest I'm sorry quite obvious but
that's how it's done
so one sec
is better
so every website could be made into a
progressive about how adding the
serviceworker adding the manifest file
using the cache that's it
our normal no sorry the node modules
here is because I have a server file and
that's that's because I'm launching this
from node 2 n able the push
notifications so you wouldn't even need
that if you don't need that and the
other thing is click so you may have
noticed this before but there's a
manifest thing on their application so
just where you know where the service
worker thing is and where the reset
button is there's manifest and it
basically shows you the icons and
everything so you get like a visual
representation of your manifest file as
well so why is this important I have a
wonderful simulator here so I'm going to
show this to you on iOS and then I have
an Android version of this as well so
you often open Safari you go to
localhost and so far this is you know
nothing special you've seen this before
so how does this become a progressive
how does it become an app ok so in
Safari on iOS you tagged tab that
whatever button that was and then you
scroll a bit and notice there is this
thing called add to homescreen okay so
when you click on that you will see some
familiar things in there right you see
the icon that's from the manifest file
you see news that was also in the
manifest file short short name notice
the localhost / that was in the manifest
file as well so you hit add and notice I
now have an icon right or like a launch
I have it twice
ignore that that's from yesterday but
but now I have that icon and if I look
at my phone now there's no way that I
could tell whether that's a native app
that I installed from from the App Store
or whether that's a PWA that I just
added to my home screen right that's the
the whole point and remember in the
manifest file we said stand alone
whatever that option was so it will
launch in a standalone window so when
you hit this it will start a window
which is not Safari although it's
based on safari that doesn't matter and
then now you get this app that you can
scroll through now I can't bring the
simulator of line but it would now work
offline as well yeah
sorry because of the a/c I can't see
anyone
user would get a pop-up saying would you
like to install this on your home screen
still there yes yes okay so for this
part of the room if you didn't hear the
question the question was on Android you
get do you want to install this thing
automatically
is it possible on iOS and kind of how
that works I suppose to an Android
there's still a thing I have an Android
test mobile with me which will use very
shortly and then you will see how that
works two points one is that you can
have a custom installer there's an event
that you can listen on which is I think
some like beef before install or some
something like that so you can actually
replace the Mobile's native installation
prompt with your own custom one and if
you do that that works on iOS as well
with some teeny-tiny modifications so
you can on an iOS device there's no
automatic way of doing this so iOS will
not prompt you to install something but
you can programmatically put out a
prompt to your users or have a button
that says install and then on that it
will do this automatically
okay we're next let's take a look at a
verb box example and then we will take a
look at some additional things and then
we get to the big app that I I prepare
for this workshop which is going to be
tested for the first time so obviously
because you come to a workshop without
testing any of your applications so I
think I open that home ready choose one
sack so let me close all of these first
this is
No
nope
okay let's take a look at first it's a
very simple word box example so at least
you know what it is and how it works and
I will show you a more complex example
as well that would just probably make
more sense so back to our familiar
application that has a simple h1 element
of serviceworker but if we take a look
at the serviceworker itself actually
this one you will see that it is a lot
simpler so what's happening here the
serviceworker API exposes this method or
this function called import scripts that
you see in line number one which allows
you to import any other JavaScript file
into your serviceworker whether that's
local or whether that's out on a CDN you
can just grab it so work box this is
this is how you use work box now it has
multiple sort of ways to function you
can use it by a CLI to auto generate a
serviceworker
you can use it using your favorite
module bundler so you can use it by a
web pack gulp grunt etc but the point is
that you know if you want to use it you
have to somehow import it and this is
how you do it in your serviceworker file
you say import scripts and it's my bad
they are now at version four point
something so that's the kind of older
version and if you import that file it
exposes a verb box global so if that's
available that means that work box is
loaded and then notice what we have here
work box dot pre-caching the pre cache
and root so this is something where
broke box is doing its magic so adding
that line and then generating the
serviceworker based on this I'm going to
show that to you in just a second
actually let me show that to you now
this is the the service work of build
script very simple take service worker
dough depth OGS that's the fire that
you've seen just now generate the
service worker the GS file based on that
and the most important thing I think is
his global patterns so remember before
we had the files array where we had
index.html AB dot CSS AB dodgiest now if
I would had 200 CSS files and JavaScript
files I would have to help enter that
manually because there's no way that you
can have a regular expression using the
cache API and the serviceworker api
natively arrives word box to us that
allows you to specify global patterns
and say you know what star GS CSS HTML
it's going to cache all of those ok so
when you run this build script it will
generate a serviceworker file and what I
want you to notice is that I kind of
modified this let me know build so this
will hopefully regenerate this for us so
it will close this ok serviceworker cool
so what I want you to notice is that it
basically expanded the pre cache and
route array that we just put in there so
what work box causes I think is like a
placeholder and it added all the CSS and
JavaScript and HTML files that it found
in the project where we've that specify
this using the build script it also
added ones that shouldn't be there ok I
should have excluded some there's no
point to have the builder dress in there
but ignore that for now and also notice
there's a revision what do you think
that revision is for
why would you want to have the hash of
the file in there
exactly
so using this approach workbooks will be
able to automatically figure out which
files to update in your cache and which
not so it will take a look at the
revision number and if I modify at the
GS the revision is going to change
therefore workbooks will know I need to
remove that from the cache and add the
new version all of this is done for you
behind the scenes kind of automatically
whereas if you would write this using
the cache API and the serviceworker api
we would be on a two day workshop just
on that because it's very very complex
ok and when you launch this app there's
one more difference which may not have
been that obvious before okay so the
result is going to be the same and if
you look at the cons oh and I'm actually
a flute no I'm not of mine you look at
the console there are some were books
related messages in here these messages
only appear when you are working on
localhost so whenever you publish your
PWA and it uses workbooks it will not do
logging ok so it's it intently knows
whether it's on the coast or not it's
responding to things it shouldn't
respond to anything but as I said you
know reset the thingy so when the first
time when you load it is just going to
say
it's going to say nothing
okay
what did I do
clear I'm I'm online maybe do it maybe
do it this way
oh we're box is loaded okay so it
Prakash is five files now this is an
important difference between what we've
seen before and how we're box works and
the key to understanding this is in this
term pre-cached so think about this you
have a website you load it for the first
time yet the service worker is going to
be installed activated and ready the
next time you refresh that website
that's when the service worker is going
to do its job for the first time right
because at the initial load is just
activated itself it wasn't there right
workbooks can do pre-caching so even on
the first load it can not only activate
the service worker but at the same time
also put things into the cache which
means it eliminates that extra sort of
refresh need for the application okay
this is what the term precache refers to
so now if I go offline everything works
okay so all I needed to do was add one
single line of code run that build
script and everything has been taken
care of me in a much more I think easier
way than having to type all of the same
ok and now I get all this version or
revision control as well out of the box
so this is one thing that where books
can do but let's take this to the next
level because what can go I close this
because it can do a lot more
the workbooks plug-in example
and normally people ask me this question
and and that's a very legit question as
well because so far what we've done was
taken a look at websites that were kind
of they only had tax try there was
nothing visual about them and and
usually what people ask is that's really
nice what you're doing there but can you
cash images okay so here's the answer
our updated news website a lot more
visual and a lot more visual that's just
a quick visual I designed this as well
so maybe this looks better than the
other one I take all the credit and I've
wrote all the text so just ignore that
completely it's completely fake news so
what are we doing here okay so this
example uses again an API slash API
slash news so it caches the API it
caches the static assets and it caches
the images as well so let's take a look
at the serviceworker code for this and
especially remember how the
serviceworker code I think I
deliberately didn't close it remember
all of this to get the API news put it
into the cache updated that under the
data right this was the first news page
example okay just look at the keep on
looking at this okay ugly confusing you
have no idea even I don't know what's
going on there I wouldn't be able to
write this again okay
not without Stack Overflow and Google
anyway and now compare this with
where is my serviceworker file not this
I opened the wrong thing sorry
got the books
I meant to open this one although they
work in the same way so Service Worker
file
that's it okay word box routing register
route you specify a route that you want
to register it accepts regular
expressions whatever you want so here I
just say whenever you say slash API
slash News work box dot strategies
remember the slides remember the
strategies that we talked about stale by
revalidate cache first network first is
a etc those were also methods that were
box exposes for you out of the box okay
so stale by revalidate and you pass in
options like the name of the cache
that's all what you need to do and this
is now automatically going to cache the
response from the API it's going to go
out to the network and if it sees
there's a difference between what is
stored locally and what's remote it's
going to update the cache this is what
still while we validate does okay
does this look more simple a bit okay so
this is what I said before that using
workbooks has been a really really good
thing in my life because it's just so
easy to use okay
and it does a lot more we're going to
get to this but before we take a look at
that and I will do a demo for you
so I mentioned I work at a company
called cloud Neri anyone heard about
cloud in it before you're my man and
you're my man and you're my man you all
be able in my men and women of course
all right very shortly so what does
cloud and we do in a nutshell we are a
cloud-based media management company so
you take your media assets those being
images videos and and some other things
you upload it to us and then we serve it
back to you now at this point you're
thinking the Dropbox fine but what we do
on top of that is image transformation
image optimization the same for videos
and I'm going to give you a very quick
demo of this and this is also going to
lead me to using the network information
API and doing that adaptive image
loading thing that
talked about so starting from here
this is a stock image that we have so
what happens you take an image you have
an image somewhere on your computer you
upload it to cloud Neri and then you get
an access URL which looks like this okay
so something that cloud income name of
your account slash image slash upload
and what's missing is of course the name
of the file human dot JPEG okay so this
is a raw image this is the image that
was on your computer or somewhere and
you uploaded it it hasn't been modified
in any way if you look at the network
tab if i refresh this then we should see
this so this is a JPEG image where did
it go
which is 570 kilobytes in size okay I
want you to remember 570 oh with me
what's the number 570 perfect so what
I'm going to do so what cloud and you
allows you to do is we have a bazillion
api's from angular to react to know -
Ruby - pH careful with the extension
table which you can use but we also
allow you to just directly manipulate
the URL the access you are out the image
and then based on that things are going
to happen so I'm going to add the few
the first one is Q underscore Auto what
do you think Q underscore alter is what
is what is the Q in their quality
exactly so
excuse me so what Kyoto is going to do
is going to reduce the quality of this
image in a way that is not going to be
visible to the human eye okay so what I
want you to do is look closely to this
image and what's the magic number 570
exactly
it's good that you're listening so I'm
going to hit enter and that's going to
go to our service and get a newly
generated image what I want you to see
or very focused on is whether you see a
visual difference in the newly loaded
image okay it's a very big screen so you
tell me okay it's done
is it the same
is it blurred seriously never ever has
said that before but okay let me zoom
back because that does date that's the
normal resolution okay so do you notice
something very interesting so what was a
number what is the number now okay so we
already saved a lot right so 49
kilobytes without except for you we now
visually modifying the image but but
serious if you take if you take a look
at it it's really not that visible it's
not that it's really pixelated it's
barely visible but the difference in the
size is really significant okay so we
can do a lot better than this who here
has heard about the format of web pee
few of you so basically web P is an
image format that Google has came up
with I don't know how many years ago
which basically says they they found a
better algorithm to to compress images
and Chrome and I think maybe Firefox
supports that but no other browsers
supported JPEG XR is another image
format that Microsoft has come up with
which is a better compression algorithm
than JPEG and they expect ie browsers to
receive this format so therefore now if
you want to serve the right image format
for the right browser you need to have a
jpg JPEG XR a web be and God knows how
many others right which is button and
JPEG 2000 for Safari exactly right so
it's like all very confusing now
let's add F underscore author what do
you think f is for format so F Auto
format we made that request so what I
want you to take a look at now is when I
open this header is that even though so
if you look here it's a JPEG image but
Cloudera knows that I'm using Chrome and
it knows that web P is the best
compression algorithm for Chrome so it
sends a web P file back ok remember the
magic number 570 let's update that magic
number
what was it 49 so 49 is our new magic
number okay
so web P 32 okay so 32 is our new magic
number so you think oh no way is going
to reduce that mm hm think again so
normally when you see this image you
would want to upload it probably like a
profile image kind of thing right so
this is now what thousand by its here
thousand by six hundred and eighty eight
pixels in size that's way too big so
let's say with 250 and height 250 this
is now going to generate 250 by 250
image size went down to new magic number
six kilobytes but it's not the prettiest
image right very not we can fix that so
let's say that we want it to really
create a thumbnail so we say crop this
as a thumbnail and I'm going to add this
G underscore face which is short for
gravity face so we're telling our system
find the face on this image and put that
into the center and voila okay this is
what we got and just for good measure
let's add our underscore max for maximum
radius and now we have our profile image
7.18 kilobytes the rounding obviously
increases the size a bit but we went
from 507
- what did I say eight kilobytes which
is very big savings right there also the
point of this is sometimes I see
developers taking an image and applying
css3 to reduce the size and do all sorts
of things
that's bad practice why is it bad
practice because you're still
downloading the thousand by 688 pixel
image which is 570 kilobytes which is
not that bad in you know theoretically
but imagine times 20 okay so you have
the same images same size 20 times
that's a lot whereas if you just do cool
two and a photo you reduce the size by I
don't know how many percent therefore
maybe downloading the 20 images
altogether is going to be 570 kilobytes
maybe if there's time I'm going to show
you some additional things what we do
with videos is definitely let me
actually show you one video example
before I forget because yesterday I
forgot that
question is where did I put the video
mp4
I think is this one so imagine that you
have a sport a website this hopefully
isn't going to be that loud
okay
so let's say you have a website that is
about sports and you know you want to
show a video obviously you know in a
reduced size inside that article now
this is this is an HD video and as you
can tell from the wonderful Wi-Fi
connection here it's not even loading
properly it's about ten seconds inside
and I don't know how many kilobytes or
even megabytes large the point is is
that and that this is related to some
what - web performance and some what to
progressive web apps as well the thing
that you need to remember with regards
to progressive web apps and web
performance is the fact that as I said I
think on the very first slide that this
web app should be made available for
everyone regardless on what connection
they have and what device they are using
therefore on an older device I think
Google now has this Motorola something
as their test device which is a very old
device and if you want to have a really
good PWA you should be able to run it on
that side with all on that device
without a problem now there are two
things that you need to remember first
of all some of your users who use your
site or your web app or your progressive
web app may have some very old devices
you should still give them a relatively
good experience in using your site
because otherwise they were just you
know and leave and never come back
second thing is that not everyone has
access to you you know 4G and 5g and
very super fast Wi-Fi networks and that
leads me to two things first of all
expecting someone to load this video
unlike a 2g connection it's never going
to finish right it's never going to load
second of all also if they have a 2g
connection that may mean that the data
plan is not endless they may have
hundred megabytes per minute just
downloading this 50% of it is gone in
like what ten seconds right you don't
want to do that to your users so one
idea is so this is our videos one idea
is to instead generate an image for them
now in cloud anair all you need to do is
stay that mp4 and just type in jpg
now you have a steel image which is in
the this is the middle frame from the
video you apply a photo Kyoto to this
and now you have still given a visual
experience to users but they're going to
download two or three kilobytes worth of
of an image right so this is again just
making sure and remembering the
experience for your users okay so they
should be able to have still a visually
experience regardless of what connection
they use where they are and what mobile
device they use okay
do you wanna have a break because I
realize I've been speaking a lot for
like an hour and a half now so let's
take a quick break
mmm 10 minutes work so everyone so
that's ten minutes pass half so that's
what 340 the 240 we're going to resume
with discussing this app
really
yeah man I'm sorry I stand corrected
because the last time when I tried it
was like down lisore it probably has
many difficult problems but everybody's
a funny little guys Steve the dinosaur
thank you
I've seen the screen so many times at
the 404 speed yeah yeah I never realized
there was a game hidden beneath it it
was the first time you've seen it okay
storage and the data so what this does
it says cache images from in this case
from cloud nary but it could be local
doesn't matter
so cache images but only add 50 images
to the cache no more purge on quota
error true means that if you go above 50
then delete the oldest one so you get
this nice rotation so you will never go
above 50 image assets inside your cache
okay you can set this number to 10 25
100 remembering you know the sizes of
your images and the storage that you
have available but I think 50 seems to
be like a good starting point so does
this make sense so far you understand
once you understand how work box works
at the moment right how easy it is to
use okay that's good yeah
is taking into account the errors one I
think the because we set this to true
yes I think I would need to look it up
in the dogs but I think I read it once
that says if you magic sorry if you run
out of space I think if we just start
deleting it I think it's this option
that sets it okay so line 52 cloud aneri
plug-in what does that do so as I said
workbooks is not only good for creating
or for sort of abstracting away the
complexity of the Service Worker API
code but it also allows us to sort of
extend or add our custom logic to it via
plugins so cloud inori plug-in add so I
think in this example it's sort of
hard-coded in here but anyone can write
a plug-in so I created this plug-in I've
released it and then Google has added
that to their work box documentation
it's all very nice and it's there and
I'm super happy about it so you can
write any sort of extension and you can
submit that to Google and if it's good
enough they will consider it adding to
the word box tree as Docs and they will
write all sorts of nice things about you
and the plug-in so what does this
plug-in do so remember we talked about
the network information API so network
information API is available under this
navigator so we say if navigate is not
an if but we say if the navigator that
connection is available so the network
information is available then get this
thing called the effective type okay so
this is what I mentioned that this
network information API allows us to
capture the connection speed of the user
and as I said it returns a string value
4g 3g 2g or slow - 2g also remember what
I said about the serviceworker that acts
as a proxy that sits between
the inside your browser and the network
and it's able to intercept your request
response cycle so the combination of
this knowledge allows us to do this
thing here we basically look for JPEG
PNG and other type of extensions we
break up that particular URL then we
check whether the navigation or the
network information API is available in
the browser for the user then we check
for the connection and we say if they
are on a 4G connection then use qo2 what
I didn't say before is that you can pass
in flag so that it remember Kyoto that's
the automatic quality so good echo and
lo each of these is going to reduce the
quality in a more aggressive fashion so
pure Auto good I think that's a default
one so that's that is going to modify
the quality in a way that is not going
to be that visible for you echo is going
to apply a more aggressive compression
algorithm and lo is going to that's
where you will kind of start to see some
pixelation going on okay but the result
is that you get a smaller image the
lower or the slower the connection is
okay and then we then we construct the
URL you know joins and whatever and the
key happens in line 41 right here
so what we do we basically go to URL
check the network information API check
the connection of the user and then we
reconstruct the URL and send it back as
a new request right this is this should
be like the lightbulb moment of the
service worker being able to request
intercept the request do something with
it and send a modified request out to
the Internet's big Internet's right so
new URL will now contain either Kyoto
good low or I follow my work at the
compare I don't know why I'm talking
about so one of the Kyoto versions and
it's going to send that and pass in you
know just the original headers that came
in the request so the only thing that we
modify is the URL
so what this allows us to do is the
following
let's close this now so let's take a
look at this image here now let me reset
everything that's the that's the best
thing to do at this point clear go back
to online network refresh so when this
image loads where is it
okay eighty come on Jake oh come back
eighty four kilobytes okay so that is
the sort of original size of our image
and if you look at the URL it just I
don't know how much you can read that
but it there's nothing in the UHS image
upload PWA and then the name of the file
that's it okay so let's now go and do
throttling so how do i do throttling
under the network tab next to the
offline checkbox you can also do
throttling using the dev tools so you
can sort of emulate a 3g connection or
2g or whatever you can also add your
custom ones so I'm going to say first 3G
and I'm going to refresh my application
and if I now take a look at the file
that got returned by this where is it
so it's 33 kilobytes as opposed to the
8th is something that we had and if you
take a look at the URL notice queue Auto
echo and I didn't show you that but I
also added a photo just for good measure
so basically now we injected this into
the URL why because we wanted to make
sure that if someone is on a 3G device
they don't get you know we're saving
them kilobytes here and then a 3G on a
2g connection saving you know 20
kilobytes here so we have how many
background image 3 images say 20
kilobytes each 80 kilobytes we say
someone write or you know sometimes the
savings can be even bigger now this as I
said is sort of a concept some browsers
like Chrome do support this but I think
and obviously other browsers will
support this as well and I think this is
going to be a very good way to give sort
of an adaptive performance for images
for your users also remember the
progressive thing from PW a
progressively enhanced applications the
Foster speed I have the better sort of
experience I give to my user ok so this
helps you to achieve that as well any
questions on this
okay what I didn't say before hmm and I
meant to so this is for those of you are
new to service workers and stuff so
under the network panel you see these
cog wheels here so every time when you
see that that means that that response
was either coming back from the cache or
something that has to do with a service
worker okay so this is how chrome sort
of denotes or or demarcates that for you
so when you say that it means that this
file was received or manipulated by the
service worker okay so normally you
wouldn't see that so in the earlier
requests but if you scroll down you see
that for example this the news because
it was available in the cache the
service worker knew if it only returned
it from that so that's just for
debugging purposes okay
I'm just thinking what I'm for getting
but I think we can go back to the slides
because now we're going to create
another PWA which is going to be well as
I said is it work or not though we'll
see so now everyone knows about service
workers caches you know about workbooks
so we can create something so what I
came up with is an interesting app that
allows you to take selfies because why
not
so it's an angular application that uses
the angular PWA plugin now interesting
enough word box being a Google product
angular being a Google product angular
PWA does not use word box the reason for
that is twofold first of all work box
was created at the same time when
angular created this PWA plugin so there
was nothing that they could have used
and then they were concerned about some
caching mechanism in in work box and I
asked the the creator of work box just
like yesterday and the answer he gave
was I should code that he said at this
point in time I cannot give any publicly
available information as to whether work
box is going to be implemented in the
angular or not now you have it I think
that's a yes but it's fine
I think I'd you know verb box is really
cool so I think they go in to somehow
integrate into anger then we have an
interesting candidate here so anyone is
familiar with firebase fire store
I'm not dancing I want you to okay some
of you so basically it's like it's an
online real time database thing the
reason why I'm using it here is because
you will see the app in a minute you
take a selfie that image is going to
appear in a feed and then everyone else
who is opening up the app will see that
picture appearing so it's like fire
store or firebase is capable of
distributing in real time data to all
the connected devices okay what's
interesting is that it also works
offline not the redistribution but you
can still access data from firebase even
though you're offline in fact I just
learned I think a few days ago that the
latest releases that firebase and
firestore did basically any bull you
know there's like hundred-percent PWA
support for them so they support things
like authentication even when you are
offline they sync data when you go
online so this really really good stuff
that they do so definitely check out
firebase and pwh they're just Google for
that we'll use cloud iñárritu of course
store and transform those images so what
should this app do should work when
we're offline that's the whole point
while we're here and here's an
interesting point as well so what I want
this application to do is even though if
I'm offline I want to still able to take
an image of myself because who wouldn't
want to do that and then when I next go
online I want the picture to be uploaded
immediately okay so this is going to be
something that we will add as well
second time we get excited so I'm a bit
worried because as I said I've only
tested it locally but we will see now so
let me first show you how the
application looks like using this
wonderful thing here so this is my test
device which is a nexus 5 which
sometimes breaks because it's really
really old but it was a very good phone
to exact
anyway you see okay so you will see what
I'm doing on the phone here so I publish
this app somewhere I'll give you the
link but this is how it looks like what
you will notice is that in a few seconds
or did I
what wait let me let me do something hit
the big reset button as well which you
can do if you're interested on how to do
this I can show and I can do this
because no it's not on localhost let me
load this again so basically what should
happen is that I should see a
notification saying that this is a PW a
although I have installed this yesterday
anyway so on Android sorry you see it
now yeah so on Android you remember on
iOS we had the the little arrow in the
bottom add to homescreen on Android you
go at least I don't know if on all
Android versions you go to this traffic
light button and then you scroll and
there's this thing called Add to Home
screen and then you get something
similar to what we had before right so
there's a custom icon the name and some
additional things so let's add that you
see that it's adding Oh someone the
notification arrived who was asking me
that
who was I talking to about the
notification from the news app I was
talking to someone I can't find the face
anyway it worked it's here doesn't
matter so Eddie - I don't know if you
can read that by says Eddie - homescreen
we haven't okay let's wait for the
advert because I'm using a free version
I'm not paying for this thank you this
is not the PWA okay before before you
that's that's not it it's just it's
visor that I'm using yeah and it's as
you saw at support it so I installed it
self limiter is available as an
application so I can now open this right
so it works inside it's only two little
window at the moment i refresh this
there's nothing so let's do capture so
let's do this
okay I got two options retake photo use
photo I will just use this terrible
photo and when we say use photo it is
going to go back to the feed uploading
to cloud and reapply transformation boom
it's there so what happens when I now go
offline okay so I killed the Wi-Fi I'm
also in airplane mode so I'm not
connected to the Internet the applique
let's close that and our moment of truth
you are offline the image should show as
well okay okay so it warns me that I'm
offline on two different locations you
can't see the hee-ho so it burns me on
two different locations there was a
snack bar notification that went away
I probably overdone this is just trying
to show you what you can do in order to
tell you users that they are offline
okay but I can still the point is I can
still see this and use the app I can use
it to the extent of taking a picture I
should put a different face now okay and
notice now I have used photo and upload
later as opposed to just use photo
because I'm offline right so I say okay
this is this is good enough so let's use
this since you are offline your photo
will be uploaded next time you go online
all these you know messages that I came
up with okay got it
so let's rien able the Wi-Fi come back
to the app and be patient because this
is an old phone but what should happen
is that at some point in time it should
find that there's a Jace comp network
somewhere it didn't so let's help it oh
hello
Jas Camtasia
mmm what is that - gee is that like a
really a 2g speed now I'm asking I
really don't know
oh is it 2 gigahertz so I should look
let's connect to that done GS :
okay so Jay s con fascia connects saved
great but the Hawkeye connecting ok so
quickly you can still see everything ok
waiting for the network at home this
worked a lot better I have to tell you
nope retry what sir yeah I did
connecting this is not it's not
connecting connecting but the other one
doesn't even appear you see connected no
internet
wait connected no internet allow USB
debugging what yes and now you can't see
so it says uploading photo taken at
whatever time and it will go back to the
feed and you we would see that thing but
this everything now just broke so you
get the idea right of what's happening
okay so how to do this I wanted to do
like live coding with you by thing we
won't have time to do that anyway so it
now just uploaded okay so now I have
these two images so what I want to do is
so if you want you can try this app as
well I tell you one thing
iOS Safari mmm don't expect magic okay
it kind of works like the video feed is
super laggy
I don't know why you have to press play
then you pause then you shrink the video
then you take the snapshot and it won't
work offline I'm still working on that
so if you're an Android by all means try
this also if you're not going to take
this offline you can try it on your iOS
device and the address is I think I
already put it somewhere here it's this
one
can you guys read put it in
black and bald at least I think that's
the one but let me quickly track that
I actually used a different version of
it but hopefully that's going to work as
well let me load this
so let's put it here let's put them
there okay
somewhere in the app it does say that I
will delete the images that you take
okay promise so feel free to try it and
I'm going to delete all the data later
on you're getting an error saying but
now it works I think it's probably
because the network is slow trying if
you if you want to if you don't want to
use your phone you can also use your
laptop it should work on your laptops as
well and what we should see if someone
is brave enough to take a picture it
should appear in the Phaedo matically on
everyone's device who is connected to
the website so what is enabling that is
the is firebase right oh come on who did
that it's selfie mater it's selfie
anyway so what enables this is firebase
right so firebase basically as I said is
like an online and I went blank was the
word it's not distributed database
online that it sends all the data out to
the connected I don't know the word oh
so you're trolling the system okay it's
fine
WebSockets but there's a real-time the
firebase is real-time database so every
connected device is basically going to
see all these updates because the
database receives an entry and then it
pushes out the update to everyone who is
looking at the site either on mobile or
on web and someone is trolling my
application quite badly
also what I do is obviously I do that
phase detection thing from cloud Neri so
that's why you take a picture even
though your face is not in the middle
it's going to generate an thumbnail
where you see your faces in the middle
I'm you for demonstration purposes okay
so this is the app if you try this on a
mobile you can try to bring your mobile
of edit to the home screen trying to
bring it offline and play with it and
see whether that works also one more
thing so I really wanted to show this to
you but I can't get back to the GS conf
Asia who is connecting now to Jos
confession yes
okay so let's try to do this again
[Music]
vizor no devices
dum-dum
why's our
ok so let me do this USB enable USB
debugging and ROI thing settings I'm
doing this because I want to show you
something in particular on this Android
phone so just bear with me for one
second to like any about this thing
again build number tap it seven times
okay connected mmm why's or crate
okay I give up sorry I don't know why
this is now not working anymore I'll
show you another example so believe it
or not as of I think two or three weeks
ago
you can run Microsoft edge on a Chrome
device as well Chrome you see it's
getting late on a Mac device okay so
this is Microsoft edge running on my
macbook so what happens and this is the
same behavior that you would see on an
Android device as well I don't know if
any one of you has opened the Android
device on the bottom it should have said
something like Add to Home screen or
something automatically right some of
you are nodding so this is because this
is a PWA Android and Chrome
automatically detects that and offers
you the the actual installation
automatically okay if it didn't offer it
to you you can always tap traffic lights
add to homescreen so what's also very
interesting is that if I open this PWA
on an edge browser what should happen is
that at some point in time notice that I
get this plus icon that says install
okay so this is in the address bar of my
edge browser I can click on that and
what I will get is this installation so
also this the edge browser now detects
that hey this is probably a PWA and it
offers me to install that automatically
so I can click install and what this
will do it will actually give me this
separate window that I can use just like
an application okay
so that's this is where this is what you
should envision when you think about the
progressive web app you go into your
visitor site using the browser it acts
as a website but you install it and it
kind of looks and feels like an
application ok so this is the core
premise of this progressive web app
hmm
okay so so I have I can show you the
Microsoft edge go away I can show you
the the code base for the application so
I have prepared two separate
repositories they are well hidden here
so let me make those black and both so
someone when someone's asking me during
the break whether I am going to give
access to the repositories so this the
two links that you see on github are to
the self emitter examples one is the
starter just a standard angular app no
PWA nothing you want to take it offline
it won't work final is what we should
have arrived to so that's the working
version I'm going to show you some bits
of the code as opposed to try to code
that together and I did show you some
very basic serviceworker examples as
well before and some very basic word box
examples I wasn't actually prepared to
show those so I will add those
repositories to my slides and then you
will get access to the slides you will
be able to access those as well okay but
for now just take a look at these I
think I made them public so if someone
could just quickly try that I think I
just did that okay so remember the
starter if you check that out you do an
NPM install and then you do and here's
the thing ya for the starter you can
just do an NG serve if you're familiar
with angular that's going to start an
HTTP server and then you can go to your
browser and check that out for the final
version because it uses the Service
Worker ng serve will not work you either
do ng serve - - prod I probably should
have added this in - somewhere in that
so ng serve - - prod or you actually
have to build your application which is
ng build - - project okay so it's either
the - just remember that when you have a
progressive web app and you use angular
you need to make sure that you've run
production build of that so what we will
do because of lack of time I'm going to
explain to you the final version and
just if you want you can or just you can
look at my screen because I'm going to
talk about this anyway
just take a picture make sure that you
know where that is and then later on you
can come back to it and check it out
well literally check it out actually
okay so
I'll sit down for this if you don't mind
I just closed it I just so did I closed
it so okay
hmmm quick show of hands who is here
familiar with angular and everyone else
is not familiar with angular ok it's
fine I will try to concentrate on the
PWA bits and and how this is achieved
sort of agnostic to the angular context
because this contacts this you know
storing something in local storage
uploading when you're flying could be
applied to whatever else it doesn't have
to be angular so for those of you are
interested in angular what what you need
to do and actually I prepared some steps
as well but basically you do ng add at
angular /pwa that is going to add all
the files and all the support necessary
for the angular project to be able to
act as a progressive web app as a next
step you need to configure how the
serviceworker works which you can do in
angular using the ng SW so the angular
serviceworker config JSON file and in
this file I have and you know this is
slightly different from what we've
discussed but still follows kind of the
same pattern so what we have here is an
asset group app prefetch all the static
assets for the application which is
really just the index.html file and all
the CSS and all the JavaScript files
okay we've done this but in a slightly
different context using the
serviceworker okay so this is just a
config file that does that and then what
we have is the second section where we
specify some URLs that I want to cache
so these are sort of external
third-party resources right so fonts
what is it yeah fonts and excuse me
phones and the cloud meri image assets
right so I want to make sure that the
serviceworker is aware of that and it
can cache it now the way this angular
PWA thing works
it's kind of similar to word box in a
sense that you specify regular
expressions and then angular is going to
gel
the service worker based on this config
file okay so it's automatically going to
January that way so you don't need to
manually write the service worker so no
for next does the view SSG huh
okay so for Knox remember from my slides
it actually uses word books so when you
use Knox I think you just I did that
before I can't remember you type in some
sort of a command it creates you a blank
Service Worker where the first line is
going to say import script workbooks and
then you add your own word box project
to that and as I said for react so I
don't know any react developers I'm not
really good Oh everyone's like ooh I'm
not that good at react on beat me up I
don't think there's a separate plugin
for it but you can just add the Service
Worker file and register it and just get
on with your life or use workbooks
that's it I don't think there's a plug
it's either one yeah so if it's
something simple use the service or KPI
if it's something more complex like you
want to try this adaptive image loading
in a react context you know you create a
serviceworker
import work box write your code add that
to your index.html file
you know the registration script and
that's that's all what you need to do
for something more angular is obviously
a larger framework than react it's
slightly more complex so probably that's
why him that's why they have this oldest
config of trance but again this is you
know somewhat similar to to what we've
seen before
okay I also created a service actually
this was quite tricky so if this is
going to be interesting for for those of
you who are angular developers so I had
an issue whereby I had used I actually
forgot what I used so I'll tell you what
this service is doing this service
basically takes a look at the navigator
dot online value so navigator dot online
either returns true or false it returns
true if you are online it returns for
when you are offline well kind of right
yeah and that's regardless of angular
right so even if you're in your dev
tools you just type in navigator dot
online at this point it should return
you true because you are online you
check that offline checkbox in dev tools
and it should return you false so what I
do here I created this observable to
actually check whether check the change
between the online and the offline State
in the browser ok and this is going to
be important because this enables me to
do many many things right this enables
me to notify you whether you are offline
or off or online using that red little
bar on top it also allows me to say if I
was offline and now I am online I want
to check local storage and if there is
something in local storage I want to
upload that so I just separated this
logic into this service now the problem
that I had and I had to take a look at
there's a very good talk on angular
observables by Joe I forget the guys
name he did a talk at angular something
conference last year or maybe earlier
earlier this year where he explains how
the different observables and subjects
and everything how that works in angular
so that helped me a lot because what my
issue was is that I have a feed
component I have the capture component
and then if I took my browser offline
while I was at the feed component then I
changed to the capture component the
browser thought I'm I'm online even
though I was offline I had to be fresh
and that's when it updated itself and
that was because I messed something up
with these observables but I can't
remember what it was but I know I had to
create this behavior subject and that
kind of solved it anyway that's only
important for angular developers for
everyone else what you need to remember
navigate or not online if your online
Twitter is true if you are offline
witters false okay so I separated this
into a service just for easy access
so at the app component level
hmm
I'm trying to look at the important bits
here so that's quite a lot of code here
but let's kind of try to pick the the
most important things here so first of
all notice line 29 behavior subject
observable the SUBSCRIBE online so I'm
going to take a look at my connection
service and I'm going to check whether I
am online or offline so if I'm not
online I show this snack bar that comes
from the angular material library it's
just you know a little snack bar that
pops up otherwise so if I am online I
check whether I have any items in my
local storage ok so if I have any items
in my local storage that means that
someone took a picture while they were
offline and I'm going to show that to
how I add that in there ok and what I do
anyone not familiar with the local
storage is basically a key value pair
that you can store in the browser so for
me the key starts with capture at
followed by an actual timestamp of when
you took the picture and then I iterate
through all of these in that local
storage ok that I find all these images
and then I take the cloud in airy API
here 43 so API cloud unit comes - we won
my cloud name so that's not much demo
image upload and what I pass in is the
actual value from the local storage
which is a I think it's a it's a base64
encoded value ok so cloud Neri can
understand that as well to upload images
it doesn't have to be an actual image
file ok so I then if I get a response
from cloud nuri I assume that the upload
was successful I removed that image from
the local storage there's no need to
store that and then I also
these lines update firebase right so I'm
updating my database I'm updating my
back-end and I say hello there's a new
entry okay and then I never gate back to
the slash of my application which is
which is the root so how does this look
behind the scenes so I have the firebase
console where I have set up a project
and if I click on database what you will
see here is a collection called captures
and these are all the images that you
have uploaded so all they have is a
public ID and then uploaded timestamp ok
so these are all the values that get
added so every time when you upload an
image a new entry gets added into this
database and because this new value gets
added and because how firebase works in
real time it pushes that update out to
all the connected devices which then you
can act on as well so what is this
public ID so that public ID I'm just
trying to put the pieces together for
you so that you understand what's
happening if I log in into my cloud in
your account under my media library I
will have to delete a lot of images now
I should have put them in a folder but I
didn't so what you will see is all your
pictures appearing here and the public
ID is just a unique reference ID to the
picture itself ok so I store this value
in the database so that later on I can
come to Cloud Murray and retrieve the
image also notice that the images that
you see here are the raw images even
though in the app you see the
transformed versions of the images right
you see the little rounded zoom on the
face ok so public ID in firebase that
reference is cloud meri
so far so good at least I hope does this
kind of make sense so far ok
hopefully so capture component has the
actual video and the canvas so what
happens here is that you get a video I
get a video feed that's from the camera
and when you take a picture that image
gets inputted to this canvas element so
that's when you remember you took a
picture and then you had a still image
in place okay so this is what achieves
that there's some additional logic in
here using you know ng-if probably does
an equivalent in every other framework
so we say if the stream is being
displayed do you capture photo and if
line 17 if we are not on line and if we
are not displaying the stream meaning
that we've just taken a picture so we're
showing that picture and we're offline
then the button says useful to end
upload later so it's just a logic to
show the different buttons furthermore
in capture components
what should I show you what should I
show you that doesn't matter you can
always check how I got the actual feet
from the camera but that's kind of
irrelevant now what's important is the
use photo okay so use photo is a method
that also checks actually I did
navigator online I probably should have
used my service ignore that so I check
whether I'm online or not so if I'm not
online
meaning that you know I don't have an
active network connection I basically
call local story step set item and I
store the captured image in local
storage as a key value pair where the
key is captured at and the time taken
and the value is the actual capture
which is a data URL of the canvas
element image JPEG so that's line 88
okay otherwise so else if I'm online I
just call the cloud in your API I upload
the image if I get a response from
cloudera saying upload was okay then I
remember this capture collection that's
in firebase I just add a new item to my
firebase database because that new item
gets added firebase pushes that out to
all the devices and you see an updated
feed okay
now what's interesting is the firebase
integration so firebase even though it's
an online real-time WebSocket based data
store as you so even though when we're
offline it still showed us some data and
so even if you so I'm using angularfire
store which is the angular firebase
library I don't know how to explain
that's like the if you want to use
firebase with angular use angular fire
that's what I'm trying to say and if you
wouldn't have this enabled persistence
when you when you call when you actually
add the anger the firebase
implementation we wouldn't see the
images that wouldn't work okay
it's it is only because I've added this
enable persistence that enables us to
see the images to see the data that
comes from this online data store even
when we are offline ok so this is this
is key here and this enable persistence
method is available in firebase as a
whole so you don't need to use angular
and angular fire for that if you just
work with firebase then you have access
to enable persistence regardless of
where you are
any questions
so this is a massive app especially if
you're not an angular developer but
hopefully you can still take away some
things from this you can apply this to
two other frameworks luckily I have a
link to a very similar app that does
this but uses react so yay
but again the concept there is exactly
say it's not using firebase there but
the concept is the same local storage
navigator online offline make sure that
you act on the change if you come online
local storage has something upload image
you know same same stuff but using react
and as I said you could use any other
framework so besides this are there any
questions on this so you have access to
both the starter and both the final code
which is this one feel free to have a
look at this run it test it if there's
any questions then you can just email me
Twitter tweet me LinkedIn me whatever
and just ask away we'll be more than
happy to help the last thing I want to
talk about is lighthouse because we
didn't talk about lighthouse itself so
let's take our app I actually never run
the lighthouse test with we disapp but
it's going to be interesting to see so
as I said lighthouse you can use that as
a CLI to so you can just npm install
lighthouse and run it locally or you can
run it wire dev tools and it's under
audits
yes under audit and notice that you get
some options here you can say you want
to test on mobile or desktop so that's
the desktop it can do a lot more but I'm
not interested in the performance nor
the best practices I just want to make
sure that you know I pass the
progressive web app test I'm not going
to do throttling so you can also do
throttling for 3G and 2g clear storage
yes so run old it so I don't know how
long this is going to take whether this
is going to work but I'm pretty
confident that I've added everything
in order for this to be a proper PWA if
not then we will check another example
so what this does just for those of you
not familiar with lighthouse it's too
slow it's fine so what it does it has
certain tests okay so by default it
gives you tests for is it fast and
reliable is it installable and I'm going
to scroll through those what is
important to remember is that this
lighthouse tool is also based on plugins
so you can come up with your own tests
again you can submit that to Google and
then they're going to either include it
or not but even if they they don't
include it you can run lighthouse
locally with your own tests so ignoring
the fact that it's a very slow site
installable uses HTTPS PW optimized so
we get a few warnings manifest is
missing a single icon we could probably
fix that but we are in a very good state
right we got a lot of green checkmarks
okay so this is showing us that okay
this is a relatively good progressive
web application okay so now what you
could do of course you could take a look
at this why is it loading to slow add
that icon and then you will get an even
better result mm-hmm now on all the
versions of Chrome I don't know if you
guys do auto updates or not you may get
a different view they used to have like
a score of 100 and I need to say you
scored 86 out of 100 for your PWA so if
you see that that's an older version of
lighthouse but feel free to have a look
at this we also have this is still
running so we can do a local audit for
this this uses images so no performance
no best practices so let's see how this
one is going to do how I stopped that
yeah
when is in next
so they specified certain thresholds
like for example now you see I got red
warnings everywhere because it only uses
HTTPS nothing else you know there's no
money first file it's not optimized
there's no viewport tag so all of these
things if you add all of these then they
say it's a proper PWA so what I'm going
to do I'll try to find this site real
quick I've run it and then rerun the
test and see if we can get some better
results I wish I could know what that
example was
No
okay so node server the Jess 81-81
go away
Oh ditz plus
Oh
okay so run this all it
I think this one has most of the things
that it are required okay so start your
doesn't respond okay so there's still
some things that I would obviously
there's no HTTP there's no splash okay
so there's probably more than I thought
that we would need to fix but at least
it gives you a good sense of knowing
what you're missing you fix them and
then you're going to be ready - ready to
roll with your PW hmm let me also try
one more thing because now I think this
little thing works okay so view
yay okay so what I will try to do is
redirect 8:08 one to localhost:8080 home
screen thing hopefully that's going to
pop up so what is it 8 0 81
still doesn't show anyway I give up
sorry there should be a little pop-up so
if towards the bottom of the screen to
say Add to Home screen why it's fine
okay so last few slides so these are all
links to articles some are kind of order
but these are all related to the last
three are very fresh
so I don't know when that happened I
probably should look that up but you
know in Google Play traditionally
speaking when you look for an app it was
an Android coupling something app right
but Google has changed that so they now
allow you to submit progressive web apps
and people just can search for that
download it from there and it will you
know you wouldn't know the difference
whether you have a proper app or a
progressive web app the same is true for
Microsoft Store and as you saw Microsoft
edge automatically detects these pwace
as well so I show that to you a few
minutes ago
iOS 13 so obviously Apple recently had
this how do they call it the WWDC
something conference where they
announced iOS 13 what they didn't
announce is that they will have a lot of
improved pwace support as well this is a
link to an article that discusses those
changes and on Google i/o about what a
month ago two months ago Google said
that they now support so if you have a
what do they called Chromebook pixel
book that runs a Chrome OS pwace are
automatically going to be supported
there so that means that you can install
an app it's going to be added to your
launch bar and it's going to act as a
standard application so these are links
some are to tweet some are to YouTube
videos some are to articles that you can
take a look at additional resources so I
created a PWA handbook which I will now
update because there's some updates that
needs to go in there but if you are new
to the PWA stuff that handbook
walks you through of putting together
that news application the first one the
very ugly one okay and it walks you
through the basics of the service API
how to use the cache and it shows you
the code samples and the end result
should be that you have a fully
functioning very simple but fully
functioning progress ababa these two
links are two blog posts that go into
the detail of this adaptive image
loading that we kind of discussed using
the network information API and stuff
without workbooks and with workbooks and
then this is the reacts of that I
mentioned so that is a similar
application which basically is a camera
app it allows you to take a picture and
if your offline stores in local storage
when you go online it uploads it to
cloud Neri written in react are there
any questions about anything that we
have discussed this afternoon you will I
don't know the slides are going to be
distributed right at some point I'm
asking the organizers but one is hiding
behind the column do you know if these
slides are going to be distributed
probably they will and then they have to
be ok I'll make sure maybe I will tweet
about this as well what this design
change also remove these all my Twitter
handles but how I put them back in just
a second I'll make sure that you get
this and I will update this with the key
table links as well so you have access
to those as well sorry any any other
questions yeah
I'm really wondering how does this
compare in your opinion - if you get
four like it if you want to make like a
mobile application others this compared
to if you want to make a mobile app case
using rapid technology I mean how does
this compare to like using something
like other technology so one obvious
difference and in that Google i/o talk I
think the the Google team gave away an
answer to your question
they basically showcased sketch which is
like this design app and they showed
three screenshots one was a PWA one was
working on a Mac and one was working on
an iPad or some sort of something and a
key what they said there was that is the
same codebase it was exactly the same
code base running on three different
completely separate devices one in an
app one in a browser and I think that's
the key right so think about this this
selfie thing that we did right so let's
say you have this angular app and now
you want to have a mobile version of
that so yeah now you would have to you
know recreate this entire new project
using one of these technologies like
Cordova or ionic or whatever with this
you just say okay ng add angular PW and
you continue to work on the same code
base with minimum money modifications
and you will end up having the same
result essentially that depends that
depends if you again I'm just going to
reference Google material here they have
a lot of use cases and showcases and
comparisons with regarding to
performance and user retention and they
give you all the percent which is an all
the dollar values that you ever wanted
and the other thing is that what I want
to say
the other thing
that was another thing no it's about the
what was your question again say the
question again let's just replay the
conversation down I have it I have it
sorry obviously there are some things
that you can't access from the browser
that you would be able to access from a
native mobile app right I I want to say
an example you can see the camera you
can't use so for your fingerprint
readers right you can you there is now a
proper I don't know what state that is
in at the moment but there's this web
authentication thing that has a
fingerprint API which is which means
that the browser's would be able to read
that as well but it's in progress okay
so there's lots of things again if you
check that Google i/o talk they have
this nice sort of timeline they will
also support I think that's all though
that's relevant to the Pixar book that
their progressive web apps if you run it
on a Chromebook or Pixar book they will
give you native file system support plus
they will have special extensions that
you double click and they will open in
progress civil apps so they make a lot
of efforts to making progressive web
apps come up to par with native mobile
apps so there are something that you
can't do but as the web progresses
there's going to be a lot more that you
can do and and that's when there's not
going to be a difference between a
traditional app and the pro ed of
web-based progressive
to the allowing or maybe they are
amateur it always going to yeah it's
always going to depend on the vendor
support so whether Apple is going to
ever add the web authentication API with
the fingerprints to Safari big question
mark
no one knows maybe they will maybe they
want you know but then you know you may
have just a news app that you want to do
that doesn't need a fingerprint reader
right so it's it's always going to be
dependent on what you use cases
okay so let's this thank you slide but
I'm going to go back to the very very
first one that's why you find my Twitter
handle that's right there it was as I
said removed from the when I change the
slides doesn't matter so feel free to
contact me there if you have any
questions as I said if you have
questions about becoming a developer
expert let me know if you have questions
about cloud Neri let me know before I
forget I brought you stickers lots of
stickers I don't know if someone was
already saw this on Twitter
I have whoopsie cool cat okay it's a cat
wearing a hat it's these are all cloud
and restrictors by the way and I have
their being unicorns that's the one that
people I know that's a few people okay
so I'm going to open this feel free to
take all of them because my bag was full
of this so yeah any questions about
anything tweet me and thank you very
much for your attention today
[Applause]
[Music]